with your guts
anyways welcome back to another episode
it don't appropriate my culture
welcome back to another episode of big
mood uh it's the new year awesome
and we are missing one babe here just
because she is we're missing she won't
be here today but don't worry it's not
like she got kicked out or anything it's
fine i know you guys like to go all
crazy online
but i got two other pretty ladies with
me uh first i will introduce myself
i got i am gina i got i i got i got gina
here
i got tiff i got nikki yeah
and today's episode will be about red
flags
yeah in dating romantic relationships
and friendships and friendships and
yeah i mean basically anyone that you
meet really yeah
co-workers i like that because i feel
like over the years like
especially like during our 20s we and
younger we overlook
so many red flags because you know we
don't know don't know our boundaries we
just don't know
we want to be nice to people and we want
people in our lives and then when you
hit your 30s you're like i don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah these are my red flags i think also
like you
can kind of know like i didn't know what
was normal and not
right when you're when you're that young
there's no nothing to compare to
but then once you get older you're like
oh you know what i don't like that yeah
i actually don't have to do this right
yeah that's true
yeah like once you get older you start
recognizing patterns in people's
behaviors and their actions and then
that's when you're like
oh i've seen this before no we're not
doing that again yeah your lashes look
really nice today
they're fake oh they're still really
nice very nice
and natural i know gina hates it when i
wear
false lashes because she's like why you
already have
such nice lashes why do you have to add
more creamy greedy it looks really good
on camera
it does they pop cuz i for me every time
i'm doing my makeup i'm like
should i put mascara on or deal with
fake lashes [ __ ] cheetah greedy
how much we suffer these asian lashes
over here i want to hear from you either
i'm only half asian um
yeah so you know i was i was recently
i've had to deal with a lot of like
really enforcing my boundaries and stuff
and
um and then another topic came up about
like
i think i saw it on tick tock a red flag
and a friendship and i was like oh my
god this would be great to talk about
so i wanted to hopefully save someone
out there that's watching this
from making from letting the wrong
people into your life when the red flags
are so
obvious exactly and another thing too is
that i
at that at the time where i was dealing
with really toxic people
um they're very manipulative and like
good at like getting you to believe that
you're crazy and i really struggled with
that because um while i was dating a
narcissist and they cut you off from
like all
all of your close friends and family
that's really great um and so then you
don't have anyone to like
bounce it off of like hey am i crazy or
is this like normal
so you just believe everything that they
say because you think that they'll they
love you so they have your best interest
in mind so
for anyone out there who maybe uh these
signs resonate with
and you were like am i crazy or or not
or am
i being an [ __ ] and my partner is
crazy
or you know whatever you're not alone
right true and it's good to have friends
like that because i can't even count how
many times i went to you guys in the
group chat like guys
am i being insane right now and then i
will try to
uh tell the story my side is or both
sides of the story as unbiased as i can
and there are times when the girls are
like
yeah you need to calm down you know so
you can't have someone cut you out like
that but let's start off with the red
flags
go ahead tiff what's your red flag well
because right now we're talking about
friendship specifically that that's
what's in my mind the forefront of my
mind
and for me a big red flag that i know i
won't stand
for in the future is when a person
uses you like your supposed friend
uses you for like but of a joke but like
using your
personal intimate details that you
shared with them as a butt of a joke
that right there is like what the [ __ ]
like why would you do that and then
that's
that's actually happened even like in
high school like i would see that
pattern but then
not until my adulthood that's when i was
like wait this ain't right
like i'm not i'm not gonna stand for
that anymore but the reason why
i would let it slide a lot is because i
was always that girl that i'm like
oh i'm cool like i'm chill like yeah
that doesn't bother me
that that was a funny joke like yeah
you're so funny it's only
called like oh you're so sensitive
exactly because dude like whenever i
would say anything
that would bother me then immediately
particularly with these people
they instead of listening to the fact
that like my feelings were hurt or like
that kind of crossed the boundary that i
had
or like you know don't be leaking my
private [ __ ] out there for the butt of
your joke like
whenever i would express any of that
these people would use that
and call me out for being sensitive and
saying like oh you just can't take a
joke like
like just like this wasn't that serious
but now you're making it so serious
or they would just twist it to turn it
around to make it seem like
i'm the one that is crazy and i should
not be tripping over something so
insignificant like they determined that
it's insignificant exactly
for right you shouldn't be bothered by
it yeah i don't like anyone that
sets other people's boundaries for them
exactly right you know tells you what
like oh well you shouldn't
be bothered by that or yeah you know
that's not a big deal that's the thing i
always heard online that said
you don't get to decide if if you hurt
someone's feelings if they say they hurt
that you hurt their feelings
then you did you don't get to decide for
them like no i didn't you know right
and i feel like um if you're making a
joke
at the expense of someone else and that
person's not laughing you're not funny
you're being a dick
yeah yeah exactly because i love
roasting
my i mean steve and i just roast each
other all the time and a good roast is
like one that you just didn't see coming
where you're just like oh that was so
good that was like a good callback and
it was like done
well but if at any point the other
person
they're such stand-up comedians oh look
at that call back to the person
you know very professional terminology
but as soon as someone's not laughing is
when it's like oh [ __ ] i'm sorry
are you okay like i didn't mean just so
you know like i was not trying to
and it's always just like it should be
oh hey
i crossed a line i am sorry i didn't i
didn't mean to
yeah um and if it's if it's not that if
they're like hey what the [ __ ] like why
are you getting so butt hurt like that's
a huge red flag
exactly and that just shows like how
selfish and narcissistic they are in
that situation they can't
see past their own nose and realize that
they're hurting
the supposed loved one and then i mean
it digs even it's like salt in the wound
too because it's like
if okay a couple times i've been like in
a group situation
and um it's actually there was a group
that i was part of that uh
sexually no actually she said oh
actually
it did sound like sexual oh [ __ ] sorry
actually actually that was a group that
i was part of sexually
okay a lot of group things a lot of
group activities i was uncomfortable
no no i was i was part of a group and i
wanted to fit in and i was also the only
girl of the group
and so this group roasted each other a
lot
but a lot of the times all of the guys
would gang up on me
and then i had nobody like on my side
like it wasn't just an equally shared
roast it was like a them versus me
and it um a couple times i did go to the
bathroom and cry
because i was like i don't want to be
uncool because like we all roast each
other
but it just it's hard when like everyone
gets to be on one team and then you are
on the other team and i didn't know how
to like
vocalize that discomfort and then the
one time that i
did it was like they further embarrassed
me
so i was already embarrassed that i was
like feeling bad about it and then it's
like they pile on to it
i don't know um i've learned from that
and now whenever
that happens i immediately address it
and usually the people are very like
you know like how i said like oh sorry i
didn't mean that um and i think that's a
good boundary to set
right that's true how how is it that you
tend to address it
oh i'm just like oh i don't wanna go
there it's like that oh that was
that was ah ouch that one hurt or
whatever so it's like still light but
it's like
it's like oh ouch uh can we not yeah
i like if they were to say something
that bothers me i'll just be like
don't go there and then it's usually
when they stop yeah and if they don't
get the hint if they think that you're
still kidding or
or whatever then you bring up their dead
grandmother
you fight fire with fire you remember
that r.i.p in your instagram
bio gina's like so you've chosen death
you've chosen poorly yeah gina doesn't
hold back one of my big red flags that i
didn't know about i mean it's
kind of a popular term now but at the
time it wasn't really a popular term but
gaslighting
yeah oh my god like the amount of times
in relationships for one but then
friendships
um like there were there was a couple
times in friendships
where they would do something and
immediately like just
after they finished doing it they're
saying that i did that thing
wow and it was such a mind [ __ ] that i
was like
i don't even know how to address this
like
when someone's doing something it's like
me hitting tiff and being like tiff stop
hitting me
damn like i would like how do you deal
with that or like
oh no i would never hit you like that's
not me at all like what are you talking
about you're crazy
yes and then there's no third party to
like validate like
yeah are you is anyone oh my god like
who what reality am i
i can't i can't handle that i remember
one of the
common uh tactics of that in
relationships was when i was like
this is like a decade ago when i got
cheated on and
it was always you're being crazy like of
course like no like i didn't
ask for a condom for me it was for my
friend you know like
you're just being crazy you know what
like you're really you need to calm down
because you're overreacting
as soon as they deflect and they refuse
to take any kind of
accountability for themselves that is a
huge red flag for me
where i'm like this is how immature you
are this is how children deal with their
problems
like it's like it wasn't me it was it
was susie like what
yeah it's right it is like oh yeah that
was me it was that's right it is what
children do like you have chocolate all
over your face
right yeah no i don't like chocolate
you're crazy crazy insane who's joey
joey doesn't share food um one of
mine is uh it actually kind of
i've dealt with this a couple times um
the
i'm very weary of people who i'm very
weary people who don't have close
friends
or who have lost groups of friends like
a whole ass group or multiple groups
because i remember there's this one girl
that my friend dated
and she was like yeah you know my ex was
so shitty to me i lost the whole entire
group of friends
and then you know like yeah really like
how does a whole group
believe one person cut you out and then
it turns out later on that she was
insane she was like
cheating on him and blah blah she did
the same thing to the to my friend that
she was dating
yeah and i'm very weary of people who
are who just don't who cannot stay in
groups of friends for too long and
something always happens
um and people who don't have a best
friend
like have you ever met someone like who
is your best friend like who do you go
to like
if you ask me i have you guys i have my
high school friends to go to once when
things go wrong
but i've met a few people who are just
like who who is your best friend
why are you jumping from group to group
but
i will also say this this is this
doesn't um
include people who are kind of like
socially awkward who are not yeah right
who can't put themselves out there but
if you're like
hey you know like i'm [ __ ] awesome
i'm your friend you're my friend
whatever very outgoing people
but you still cannot keep a group of
friends that's a huge red flag
because in all those group of friends
that you've lost
all those friendships that you've broken
whatever the only common denominator is
you
yeah so you need you are probably the
problem
yeah because how it whenever something's
a pattern right you know and if
it's just once then it's like okay
there's an opportunity to learn we all
[ __ ] up
make mistakes um and you could you know
you could have done something in that
group of friends and then it's like oh
[ __ ] i shouldn't have done that and then
you never do it again and then you
you build new friendships but if it's a
pattern that continuously happens
then yeah you got to look within
yourself and go hmm
right maybe i'm the problem because i'm
a [ __ ] like i'm a
terrible person you're not a shitty
you're kind of nice she wishes she was
shitty just so she could wear the label
right she loves it she's got her villain
merch she's like i'm a villain i'm so
bad i'm evil
she's a [ __ ] angel she's so [ __ ]
sweet it's
killing my bread i'm gonna lose money
she didn't give us a christmas present
though so it's true oh and it is her
love language
you know whatever so she is a [ __ ] yeah
because like i like i i'm like i'd like
to say that i'm not the nicest person in
the world
but even i am capable of having close
friendships of over a decade see here's
how i see you gina i
i see you as i see you as being very
similar in certain ways except for when
you get mad you get vocal
and i just shut her down but um
when you give everyone a base level of
kindness you know you meet someone
you're not
a [ __ ] to anybody like you're not that
like hard exterior like they got to earn
it
like you give a base level of kind
kindness everything that base level is
pretty high it's pretty good
nor like other people like their base
level kindness is like here gina's is
like here
yeah yeah you're really there it's like
you make people feel included you know
everyone starts off equally
then if they do something then they go
down a notch
you know and then like maybe they can
earn it back or whatever but i feel like
i feel like we are pretty fair and i
feel like that's how i would want all my
friends to be um
because i think my bitchiness is usually
just
yeah you know yeah like i i don't go out
of my way to be malicious
yeah um there has to be a very almost
gotta earn your bitchiness
right yeah like you really gotta earn me
being like
mean to you yeah but can you guys stop
it my fans think i'm a thug so can you
guys oh
sorry i mean she the other day scary hit
me with some brass knuckles and i was
like ouchies it's ruining my brand
but yeah so it's like i i'm very weary
people like that and that also ties into
uh relationship and dating if i ever
date a guy and i hear
all my exes are crazy all my exes are
insane it's like oh it's you
what did you do you're the common
denominator it's either
it's either you or the shitty person or
there's something wrong with you that
you pick all the wrong people for you
like all the crazy ones for you so you
are the common denominator
yeah you know what it reminded me of too
when i was talking about the way you
operate
because i knew someone that was the like
opposite of that and
in a way that here's here's how here's
what it's like it's like if
they're inconsistent with how they treat
you right
where some days it's okay to like be
joking and then the next day you joke
the same way and then they're pissed at
you
or like they try to like get back at you
for something and like you're like wait
what did i we were just
it's the same and where the relationship
isn't um
clear right and then uh you're just kind
of walking on eggshells every time
you're around them
oh yeah i hate the the walking on
eggshells the walking
eggshells i would rather never speak to
that person again than have to like
walk on eggshells around them true this
is yeah that's for sure
a good red flag there because i've
definitely been in situations like that
where i'm like
why is this so inconsistent yeah no
sense like why are you
one day super lovey-dovey relationships
yeah right relationships and even in
friendships for sure or like even with
co-workers like i've had like when
i used to work at the hospital oh my
goodness it was like
high school there it was crazy but yeah
like like i had this one co-worker where
she was
she was way older than me um because
when i started working there i was
18 or 19. 19 i was 19. so i was the
youngest one and then like
this lady was like in her late
40s maybe 50s and um and so like she
would they would always refer to me as
her mini me
because like we kind of look similar and
so she used to like someday she'd be
like
oh my minnie me and whatever and be all
sweet and then another day she'd be like
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] like she was a [ __ ]
to me like she would treat me like as if
i was this stupid child that didn't know
how to do their job
and then turn around and then go talk
[ __ ] about me to my co-workers
and then go tell my boss that i was
doing something wrong when i really
wasn't
and then like my boss my boss would come
over and check
up on what i'm doing based off of this
one other lady what she said
and then i'd be like what are you
talking about like i've been doing this
one particular job like how was i
doing that other thing that she said i
was like she was lying about me and
trying to get me in trouble
but then to my face sometimes she would
be like really sweet and like try to
share her
her lunch with me and stuff and i was
just like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you lady
like and then i realized um with her
specifically
like she taught me that it's not
always about me like when people are
mean to me because
her and her life her husband like had
like lost his toes so he couldn't work
anymore and then her older kid was like
like uh doing drugs and like running
away from home and like she was
her home life was a wreck so i think she
came to work
and then like she used me as a target to
like vent out
her home life [ __ ] onto me somehow
and
i realized like oh [ __ ] it wasn't even
about me but right
but still like that was a huge red flag
like the inconsistency there
i had a boss like that he had some
[ __ ] up teeth did he gina yeah he had
some [ __ ] up teeth you know what he
could have used
he could have used candid so are you
unhappy with your smile
you don't have to because thousands of
people have used candid the clear
comfortable removable and practically
invisible gina
not like gina she's not being invisible
uh practically invisible aligners to
help straighten their
teeth and now they love their smile
so canada is here to help straighten
your teeth so you can fall in love with
your smile too
so your treatment is prescribed and
closely monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's
an expert in tooth movement you'll have
the same quality of care you'll get
from an in-office orthodontist from the
comfort and convenience of your own home
and while other companies use general
dentists candid
only works with orthodontists with
candid the same orthodontist who created
your plan
is with you from the start to finish so
you never have to wonder how you're
doing
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then and it costs
thousands less than traditional braces
become your best you start straightening
your teeth today
right now you can save 75 on candid
starter kit go to candidco.com
mood and use code mood that's
candidco.com
mood code mood take advantage of this
limited time
offer to save 75 on your starter kit
candid co.com
mood code mood are you guys
irresponsible like me even when it comes
to really really big events like your
wedding
wedding wedding oh look at you all happy
uh if you're engaged not sure how to
make your wedding happen join a million
couples who've planned their weddings
with zola
zola makes wedding planning easier and
less stressful by creating
everything couples need all in one place
from wedding vendors
save the dates and invitations free
websites registries and more
zola helps you find wedding vendors in
your area all vendors are pre-screened
so you can skip endless back and forth
with vendors who aren't right for you
like the guy who catered my birthday
zola will start conversations with any
vendor for you you can also explore save
the dates and invitations
zolo's cards can be easily customized
with different paper types foil and more
you can also create a wedding website
for free hundreds of beautiful designs
all with matching save the dates and
invitations
and you can set it up in minutes you can
also build your registry with zola
zola has the most fun and easy registry
fill your registry with gifts
cool experiences and cash funds all in
one place
use thoughtfully designed smart tools
that simplify every step down to writing
thank yous
this is great for someone like me
because i hate yeah
saying thank you thank you
just come give me my present and leave
don't even meet the fat in here
yeah god you guys are annoying i don't
even want you no dude i as someone that
had to
go through all the freaking wedding
stuff and was doing it on a budget so
like i didn't really have a wedding
planner
helping with all of that this is amazing
and you guys know i barely am able to
keep
a one day film a month yes we know you
guys
we know right now so if i had to plan a
wedding
she's hot because we didn't recognize
you because you're never here
exactly jess is usually here go to
zola.com
big mood today and use promo code save
50
that's save five zero to get fifty
percent off your save the dates
you can also get free personalized paper
samples before you purchase
that's zola.com big mood and use the
promo code
save 50. that's save five zero
and plan your wedding hell yeah
you know i was saying about like your
your co-worker i had a i had a boss like
that at a
a restaurant that i was a hostess at
some days he would be nice to me
um but most of the days he was shitty
and i realized he was nicer to
the male hosts like i was the host at
the front desk
and he would always enforce why are you
wearing why are you wearing like a
colored stripe in your shirt like you
have to be an all black all black only
all black
non-slip shoes all black all black but
my male co-workers would come in with
like
pink shirts dress shoes whatever color
shirts
i'm just like what the [ __ ] like why but
he's always on my ass
yeah he like he was just so mean to the
point where like one day i was like
i and i told him i was like hey you know
i have a friend who's who only has a few
days left because he's battling cancer
and then one day i told him i was like i
need to go see my friend
you know and what so-and-so can cover
for me i need to go
because he only has like a couple hours
left and he legit said to me
okay well if your friend dies the
world's going to move on you need to
figure out if you want this job or not
whoa
oh my god right and i was like this is a
host job i was getting paid seven
something an hour i'm [ __ ] out of
here so i ditched him like in the middle
of lunch
rush on wednesday and um but
i i learned i found out why he treated
me that way and it wasn't because of me
his wife had came in one day and she is
just
larry larry like i want something to eat
larry where are you
like where's your credit cards um no no
no he takes care of everything and i'll
put him on the phone right now she'll
call the front desk like where's larry
put him on the phone he was basically
her [ __ ]
and so he took it out on all the females
yeah
you know so people just treat you shitty
sometimes because they got
[ __ ] going on their lives and they don't
know how to handle it right it's crazy
or sometimes
it's not an excuse not excuse definitely
not an excuse but that is
it for you to deal with yourself so
you're not instead of getting
angry or taking it on yourself you can
just feel bad for them you know what
else bothers me another red flag
what people who victimize themselves yes
that's actually one of the ones i was
going to say too because
i know like me myself i've done that
[ __ ] in my past and i'm like
oh yeah because then people that do that
like they never see exactly going back
to the other thing about like
what's the common denominator here it's
like yeah they don't realize that
they are the ones that are also
attracting a lot of this stuff
or we i'll just use myself as we we
don't realize that we're using that [ __ ]
and we're attracting it and then that's
just
further bringing everyone else around
you down because then they just have to
hear your [ __ ] or like
another situation where you just so
happen to be a victim in and it's just
like
training and it's like you think you're
special right because
that's the really this is a real like
victimhood
downfall is that like you think that
you've got it so bad like you have a
special
thing that makes you always get the raw
end of the deal
like something about you makes people
pick on you or
whatever that like you are just so
special that no one else goes through
the same [ __ ] that you go through that
no one else could possibly be having a
worse day or
or you know have gotten picked on like
like you that or have to deal with the
things that you had to deal with
my thing is um oh god this just makes me
[ __ ] wanna
i had to deal with this
i love when you just make sounds
have you ever like gone to someone like
hey i i really
like nikki i really don't like it when
you um when you like
touch my hair can you not do that and
then they just go
oh so i'm the bad guy all the time again
i can't get anything right
like i'm always so wrong like everything
i do is just so wrong i can never get
anything right i'm the bad guy
like just uh i like i you don't even
know how much i go through like i'm
having such a bad day and you're just
making it worse and it's just like
shut the [ __ ] up like yeah you know and
that makes people
and i don't relate to that part young
regina would be like
okay maybe i should just not bring up
things anymore and that's what they want
yeah they want you to not call them out
on their way to guilt you
to about something that they did that
made you know
yeah so instead of acknowledging it they
turn the spotlight on themselves like
i can never do anything right and i
i grew up with a family member like this
um i'll just say it's like my aunt or
something
like we'll bring up something she's like
oh so you're saying i'm the worst aunt
in the world i'm the worst i'm the worst
because what they want is for you to be
like no no no no no no you're not
like i really do like you like okay then
why are you telling me that blah blah
younger gina would have been like okay
you know i won't bring this up no no
you're a good person like i didn't say
that you know
that's a sign of narcissism yeah and now
gina's like
and i've i've showed you guys this was a
text message i went through before
now for those of you who notice that
people are doing that to you
what i do is i call them out i'm like
this is what you're doing you're
gaslighting me you're manipulating me
it's a manipulative tactic yeah
very common manipulation it's called
something i just can't remember what
it's called
yeah but it is a very common
manipulating tactic so what i do is
i call them out i'm like no what you're
doing is manipulating me right now
trying to play victim and i am going to
choose to not engage in this
conversation until you know how to speak
to me properly and i just leave
and that that forces them like they
can't use that anymore
but that has become one of my biggest
pet peeves ever
yeah that's that's a different kind of
victim that i was thinking of but oh my
god yeah i've dealt with people like
that where it's like are we never gonna
move past
the fact that you feel like it's just
it's a really annoying trait for sure
but
the kind that i was more describing
um oh i this is who i used to be
i used to be a person that um i would
talk to a particular friend
and this person would tell me like
tell me like something good that's
happening in your life because every
time we talk you just tell me everything
that's bad
and i know like that's the particular
like victim yeah one that i was talking
about that i
it's a drain yeah it's so draining
that's what that's what i was referring
to with like
it's really [ __ ] draining and i try
my best to not be that kind of person
anymore because
i realized that i actually absorbed that
from my family
like every time i'm around uh a
particular side of the family
like it got to the point where i was
like stop
we're not saying anything like we're not
complaining about anything anymore
today is this day and we're going to
have a good time like we're here at this
place and we're going to have a great
time
and i for the next like at least an hour
you cannot say anything negative they
couldn't even last like five minutes
and i was just like this is where i get
it from this is literally where i absorb
it from and i
every time i try to um every time i
catch myself
reverting back to that habit i'm like no
i'm not gonna be that person
everything's great nothing's wrong like
or you know like yeah
i'm suppressing it but like you're just
making a change sometimes you have to
overcompensate in order
to like make that change happen for sure
i knew a guy like that
and i [ __ ] you not this is a
conversation i remembered this is back
when i was 20 and i will always remember
this conversation
um it was a long time ago
it was last year so long ago
she's older than me what ancient
but i never aged i would never get old i
would never do that
but i i will never forget this
conversation because it was like
the last straw with this guy he was like
a new guy in our group of friends
and so we were talking about we were
looking
at puppy pictures like oh my god this is
so cute this is so cute
and then all of a sudden he goes i was
never allowed to have a puppy because my
family was poor
[Laughter]
and then what are we oh sorry yeah i
guess we'll stop looking at puppy
pictures now
that she cries i know i've done some
[ __ ] like that too
i know i have it's so [ __ ] funny i
should do this [ __ ] as a joke like
like when people are talking about
friends or parties they'd be like it
must be nice to have friends yeah you
know like a joke yeah but not
like dead serious that's for real
and i remember she's always just like
all right i can't i can't do this
because i noticed it a lot of times
before too but that one was just like
shut up bro boy i don't care
it's like let me drain any ounce of
happiness it's like um
what we do in the shadows the energy
yeah
exactly my boyfriend ran over my cat
like just energy vampires
yeah it's real i mean there's a whole
snl skit that debbie downers
yeah yeah that's right yeah pretty
accurate
how about some oh i got another one yeah
i got another red flag
um when people make you feel guilty for
spending time with other people
oh like that is like a huge red flag
wait can you give an example yeah so um
well this one's a relationship one but
like i had a boyfriend where
if i was gonna go spend time with my
best friend then he would be like
oh but i thought we were gonna eat lunch
together like didn't you say that we
were gonna eat lunch together and i was
like wait no but i told you i had plans
with my friend already
and he was like oh okay then go have fun
whatever and i'm like um okay i'll
cancel
because obviously i didn't want to upset
him so i'm like okay fine then i'll try
to cancel but then he would do this
frequently to the point where i'm like
wait what the [ __ ] like
i don't even care if you get upset
anymore because i need to go see my
friend like this is ridiculous you're
trying to separate me from my friend he
would do this with my family too like
he'd be like
oh so you're gonna go visit your mom oh
i thought we were gonna go to my parents
house and i'm like
you see your parents every [ __ ] week
like what are you talking about
but yeah it was it was it was really
controlling like that controlling
behavior
yeah yeah yeah yikes because okay i
needed an example because
i feel like um so i wrote down a lot of
like red flags for
dating like romantic relationships but i
feel like a lot of them
if they're not flat out toxic behaviors
like um you know narcissistic
controlling behavior
yeah physical abuse like abusive uh
behaviors um
a lot of red flags i think just come
from people having two different sets of
expectations
so maybe like if you are if you're like
the type of person that really wants a
relationship like a long-term
relationship
and the other person just wants a [ __ ]
buddy you know sometimes there's just a
difference in
um like expectations and so this person
might see
the [ __ ] buddy person as like a red flag
when really they just
want completely different things right
and vice versa like if somebody just
wants to
have sex and then they're dating like
someone that wants to settle down
um they might see the marriage stuff as
a red flag when it's like it's just
a different set of expectations it comes
down to communication with that
definitely and so with the spending time
with other people
i used to feel like or at least the
person i was dating made me feel like i
was guilting him into spending more time
with me
but it was more that he would break
dates like he would
we had an expected thing or like i
thought it was a mutually agreed upon
like
hey on wednesday they were gonna have a
date and then he would ditch me to go
with his best friend
and then i would bring up like hey like
you hung out with your best friend
mondays saturday friday
like you told me that we had wednesday
and then you know you blew me off and so
um i feel like that stuck with me like
he would he would
make me feel like i was a bad guy for
guilting him even though
he was the one breaking promises yeah
that makes sense
yeah if it's breaking like an agreed
upon event then that's [ __ ] up
yeah but yeah no with my example though
like i had already had my event planned
and then they would try to guilt me out
of it i hate that that reminds me of the
guy remember that shitty dude i dated
briefly that i ditched the middle of
arizona yeah yes
uh it was always like my ex-girlfriend
would have done it
oh i've had one of those yeah i'm like
okay then go [ __ ] go go to your
ex-girlfriend the [ __ ] or yeah
the the final straw was when um i had
told him weeks ago like i can't go to
visit your family
like in your hometown and he was like
okay i mean i guess i'll just hang out
with my ex-girlfriend while i'm there
yeah it's just like [ __ ] up you [ __ ]
five foot six [ __ ] like this is why man
that's why that's why
i mean the shout outs on my shout out or
my short kings out there but not
specifically not that one yeah there are
some nice
short guys out there but um
yeah the whole like
well i mean i need a lot of attention
this is true but you communicate that
yeah i think it's all about
communications if you
get together with somebody and you both
are very aware of each other's needs and
wants
will die and then if they don't if this
one person doesn't hold up their end of
the bargain i think it's grounds to be
like
hey yeah but i'm also very reasonable
too like family comes first
yeah like that's fine like hang out with
your friends i don't demand
sorry i don't demand percent attention
i just like a good amount of attention
and then um i've been doing therapy
awesome nice um and
my therapist said like i guarantee you
and i will put money on it i'll
bet any amount of money on it that if
you demanded someone's 100 attention and
they gave it to you
they will eventually grow to resent you
and she's like i will put
any amount of money on that yeah and i
was like oh
okay wait what do you mean 100 100
like 100 is in like okay yeah i won't
hang out with my friends i'll hang out
with you instead
yeah for sure yeah so you're getting
your 100
attention but it's it's going to get bad
yeah because people have their own lives
they are their own people too
exactly yeah hey i could never um i
don't think
i can only date someone that doesn't
require a lot of attention right
uh oh because i need my sleep man
and sleep oh sleepy girls man mattresses
need to be very comfortable especially
if you're comfortable
exactly and i got a mattress for you
nikki what do you got i got
purple purple mattress you guys have
heard me say this before on the show but
i've had my purple mattress
for i think now six years five years six
years something like that for a long
time and i'm absolutely in love with my
purple mattress it's so comfortable it
has
the purple grid which sets the purple
mattress apart from every other mattress
it's patented comfort technology that
instantly adapts to your body's natural
shape and sleep stuff they do the egg
test with that
yeah that's actually what sold me it was
a face yeah
almost 90s the cup of wine oh yeah yeah
oh yeah that too
no but yeah this egg thing they actually
put an egg on the purple grid
and then they do like uh they try
smashing it with various objects
even like a refrigerator at one point i
think and the egg won't crack
like mattress egg fridge the purple grid
which is inside the mattress oh okay
yeah yeah and then yeah it wouldn't
crack so i was just like
i'm sold and that's why i bought it the
amount of
rough sex that i have if that means i
won't crack my skull open
this might be good you will not girl i
kind of want to crack my back
sometimes yeah so this purple grit here
it has 1800 open-air channels designed
to neutralize body heat
and purple provides a cooling effect
other mattresses
can't replicate so this cutting edge
technology doesn't stop
with the mattresses every purple pillow
is engineered with the grid for total
head and neck support
and absolute airflow so you're always on
the cool side of the pillow
so uh experience the purple grid and
you'll sleep like never before go to
purple.com
big mood 10 and use promo code big mood
10 for a limited time you'll get 10
off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
big mood 10 promo code big mood 10 for
10
off any order of 200 or more
terms apply nice nice you know what else
you do on a mattress
oh cry baby making oh okay
baby do you even know if you could make
a baby
i don't know because i mean we all think
we can all of us think we can and then
we don't know because then we don't know
if our fertility is
is good that's true because i made a
baby when i was 18
i'm 31 now and i'm trying to make more
babies and i don't know what's happening
i pull out and leave up to god you you
pull out
i think you're doing it wrong that's
what's happening
that's why yeah
so modern fertility is awesome because
the traditional
guidance with fertility has always been
just wait and see like that's literally
what my doctor told me
that he's like you oh you're trying to
get pregnant okay
like do it for six months and just like
see what happens my doctor told me a
year
oh yeah she was like just do a year and
then come back
she got sick of people complaining
but now we have tools to help us plan
for and track almost everything in our
lives so just waiting and seeing about
fertility just isn't
good enough anymore that's why modern
fertility was created it's easy and
affordable and it's a way to test your
fertility hormones at home
with a symbol a single symbol a symbol
a simple finger trick it sounds like a
fortune telling
will get you pregnant give me your
finger
um mail it in with a prepaid label and
you'll get your personalized results
within 10 days
how do you take it what do you do well
your finger oh oh god
we're joking the fingers oh this is like
some sleeping beauty stuff that's cool
yeah wow you really cause
yeah okay um so traditional testing with
your doctor can cost
over one thousand dollars but modern
fertility only costs 159 dollars to get
the same information
also um if you have an hsa or an fsa
those are
health savings accounts you can use
those dollars on modern fertility oh
that's cool awesome because usually
those are for medical emergencies but
this
could be considered a medical thing so
you get insight to how many eggs you
have
hormone levels other important fertility
factors
the results go really deep into what
every hormone means so
um you can also talk one-on-one with a
fertility nurse
to review your results and options for
next steps dude i'm excited so i have i
have
uh modern fertility waiting at home for
me because you have to take it
you have to take the finger prick test
on your third day of your period
and i just started mine so i'm like
waiting for the third day so i could do
you're like you're one day behind me so
mine's tomorrow oh nice yeah yeah so
then
i'm so excited to see what my resume is
this is really interesting
oh you can tell all that just from a
little bit of blood from your finger
yeah
that's crazy you got the whole world
inside your finger that's so neat
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners 20
off the test when you go to
modernfertility.com
mood that means your test will cost 139
instead of the hundreds or thousands of
your costs at a doctor's office
get 20 off your fertility test when you
go to modernfertility.com
mood modernfertility.com ooh mono
fertility putting them fertility doctors
out of business
that's a lot of dull that's a lot of
doll hairstyles
doctor hair doctor doll hairs they have
enough doll hairs yeah
so it's very interesting like attention
because in
in like a romantic relationship i like a
lot of attention but with you guys
you've seen
i require very low maintenance
friendships yeah
yeah like you guys see me very little
but it's not even just you guys like my
friend my best friend from high school
lives literally two miles for me she
sees me like once every three months
so at the same time too when it comes to
attention
you need to know if the other person
is even able to give you that sort of
attention because it might not be in
them
you know yeah yeah cause like a as a
partner if i was dating you
like if i was a very strikingly handsome
rich doctor man and i was dating you i
don't
i i honestly cannot
i just can't give people that much
attention right like
even steve and i we won't see each other
like we both work from home
and we live together and we're home all
day i won't see them for like three days
because i just need space wow
i need to be able to recharge alone so
that i can give you all of me
and if i'm having to spend every
moment with you or like multiple days in
a row
you're getting a thinner and thinner
amount of my personality so you're
getting not
quality hangout time and i think my love
language is quality time so
if i have to spread it super thin then
you're we're just not gonna get quality
and so
um yeah love languages are so important
yes
because you know praise the praise one
can't praise oh yeah words are really
bad at the words of affirmation one
either right because if i say it
like once or even like multiple times i
assume that you now know forever
that i feel that way right like unless
something changes
that like you got you went up an even
higher notch then i'll praise you again
but then that's it like
like that's no more like you already
knew you already know that i think
that's cool
she told steve i love you once 80 years
later he's like i never heard him
say i love you a lot love is like i
could express
feelings right but like if i have to
validate you
for something that you've done i can't
do i can say i appreciate you like if he
does dishes i can say like oh my god
i appreciate you so much that i have no
problem with but it's like it's more
about the
when they need validation for
accomplishing things
that's a red flag you guys you see that
yeah i'm right she's a huge company
that's just gonna if you are a praise
words of affirmation person we cannot
date
and i'm looking today
she's on the market oh my god i don't
have a wedding ring on
oh that really does look like that i'm
so sorry steven start the rumors
start the rumors now i'm gonna i'm gonna
start the rumors i'm gonna start in the
comments i actually took a shower today
for you i'm gonna start my wedding
the attention i need is more like a part
of me is like i want to be under your
skin and wear you but um
for the most part that's not a red flag
no no no no
no no that's a green flag
[Laughter]
she loves you yeah
yeah like the ones that don't pop yeah
right
i just want to be in there i won't touch
anything i promise i just want to be
there
you know but i think my intention is
more like
um there's a comedian that said it too
it's a
i want to just be in the same room as
you i don't need to constantly be
interacting like you can just be in the
same room hang out
somewhere in the vents or something like
just [ __ ] whatever you know
and like that's what i like like just to
be in
each other's general vicinities you know
so that's cool no you have to have your
own thing
yeah because i don't even i don't like
hearing him cough
like are you sure you guys are in love
i [ __ ] love him and but we're the
same like
we are very like independent people and
then when we do come together it's so
much fun
right but and i was exaggerating about
three days it's like it's more like
a whole day like we have separate
offices
and his the warehouse is set up right
now is so perfect because i'm all the
way up top to the right
he's all the way at the bottom to the
left in a part of the house that's like
almost disconnected from the right such
a strange room
yeah it's so like you cannot hear anyone
if you're
in those two rooms um you we have to
call each other if we want
it hopefully each other but i will say i
i'll go to him if i need a hug
and he will always be there to give me a
hug and then i go okay bye
yeah yeah sometimes that's exactly just
all i need okay like even like if i text
you like
hey and just like what's up be like okay
i miss you okay bye like this
oh that's fine yeah just a little just
like not um
i can't like physically be there all the
time right yeah cause i do
like in between of both of you i think
because uh cause casey and i we work at
home and we're home all day every day
and actually isaac too like during the
week who's a teenager now gross
full-blown teenager now now we have like
another man living in here that happened
you know
i know i was like this small i know i
was able to punt him across you know you
met him when he was like five dude yeah
so crazy but anyway so yeah so then it's
like all three of us at home
all day every day and for the most part
isaac's in his room
almost the whole day he'll isaac
actually is the one that will come to us
like he's always like taking breaks
and he'll come he'll give us a hug or
he'll be like oh what are you up to
or whatever and like now that he has his
phone like he'll just like use his phone
next to me and
if i'm in the office then he'll just be
there with us but
um for the most part casey tends to
spend the most time downstairs
in the kitchen and like he'll be on his
laptop and then me i'll be in the office
so like that's kind of like where we
have our designated areas in the house
but
every meal we eat together um and then
like every break or whatever we're
always like
checking in with each other and trying
to see like oh what are you up to oh
yeah i'm doing this or whatever
so it's like i yeah i kind of like have
my alone time but then i kind of don't
because
they're still in the house and i still
like go and interact with them a lot
right so
i don't know right i don't like how if
i'm in the kitchen because i have to eat
because my stomach is making me eat
like i hate that it interrupts my
schedule and while i'm there i'm just
trying to get it done as fast as
possible and not lose my train of
thought
and then steve thinks that i'm on a
break and so he starts talking to me and
it's interrupting all of my thoughts oh
geez and then i'm trying not to like
snap because i don't want him to feel
bad that's like probably the hardest
part
of like the interactions where i'm like
he because he's like you or he's like oh
we can
we can talk now and i'm like no we can't
i can't
i can't hear you right now like i have
so many thoughts in here
i can't date you nikki i would lose my
[ __ ]
why don't you love it it's so sweet too
like he'll just be like
oh did you hear this like
i'm hungry and i need to think about
things oh geez
that's why in dating it's like nice
because like you don't see that part
like we
meet up at our pre-planned time
and i'm very prepared for it because i
got all the other stuff out of the way
and like you never see that
right but then you know you live
together and it's like oh [ __ ]
i think casey's more like you yeah yeah
casey
is i think he's like that because
sometimes i'll come up to him and he'll
just be like in
lost and thought and i'm like did you
hear what i said nope
he's like oh yeah i heard the blah blah
blah and i'm like nope you didn't hear
me
it's okay bye don't you love when people
repeat just the last words
and act like they heard totally know
that you did not hear me
i hate when you ask them like did you
hear what i said and they actually
didn't they recite everything and then i
feel like an [ __ ]
shut up stop listening to me that would
happen oh my god
no for me i love that i'm like good job
gold star okay let's keep going
like nice you were listening wrong
i'm going to call you out snarkily i
better be right yeah exactly how dare
you listen to me
cheeky ruined it um
so how about like how about like the
more surface
red flags like for instance if he's rude
to a waiter during a date yeah no oh
yeah
yeah i think all of us has worked in
service yeah
that's actually that was like one on my
list
being rude to a waiter i don't know
where my list went i [ __ ] my list suck
it
i need lists personality type a they're
going to organize my thoughts
see when i didn't do the list when i
wasn't the type a
i didn't graduate yet my life was a
[ __ ] mess
it was so jumbled and then i'm like okay
oh a list
a list it helps so much i
have laundry sitting in with clean
laundry that has not been folded into
once i do that
yeah it's hard when you don't deem the
things as important
so like you know certain things that are
really important to others and actually
this relates because
you just have to agree with your partner
on your values and your morals and your
lifestyle
and and then things will be great and
you have to be physically attracted but
if
one of those things is off that's where
you're gonna have problems and i think
it's great
because steve and i are very similar
with all the things
and um i don't see wrinkled clothes as a
problem
i don't see uh like i never used to see
clutter as a problem until we moved
somewhere that i really like
like the aesthetic of and then now i
like really get bothered by clutter
because
i worked on this like that oh the house
the house looks great by the way follow
me on instagram the house of limo really
good
nice but the rooms that you thought were
not house of green it's just lima
that's just her place i actually do have
an instagram registered
house of green and then i changed it to
the house of limo so i have both
imagine just like today i set up six
cans of monster energy on the table one
knocked over that's the house of green
that is the house of cream if you go to
steve's office
that's exactly what it looks like empty
tabasco sauce bottles
monster energy drinks everywhere i just
love how the tabasco sauce bottles
complement the colors
of the stains on the wall the house of
green the dishes piling up
it's all part of the aesthetic yeah but
i didn't do that room so
it's fine those are the rules
yeah i don't know more red flags um
i'm trying to think because when for me
um showing up late i have a huge problem
with
yeah don't look at me not for
friendships
unless it's like uh we're getting our
nails done and we have to be there at a
certain appointment time or whatever
but um like if i think broken promises
is just something i struggle with a lot
and i read that uh
that is actually part of the quality
time
love language wonder bothers me a lot
yeah
because it's like you want actions to
mean something or like your words to
line up with the the action so when
people
talk a big game and they have a lot of
words like i dated this one
guy who would plan the best dates
verbally
like he would tell me all these cool
things we should do and then we'd
set the date and then something would
always happen and we didn't do it
and i was like man you're so like this
is what i want but then your actions
are completely opposite and it would
hurt because it's like
then it develops trust issues and and it
also
um i feel unloved i don't feel loved i
feel like i'm not important to you
because
you promised me this thing and then you
didn't follow through and it doesn't
have to be big promises but just like
even
showing up right like i remember uh oh
when
steve and i first started dating i
thought that he was doing this
and that one night about yeah with the
taquitos
and i about uh yeah broke up with almost
we hadn't even officially dated yet but
i was just like no [ __ ] you
i thought you were gonna be like the
best ever and
you have this you know telltale sign
that
is just a huge red flag he yeah he's
like i'm on my way
never showed up who says i'm on
my way and then you never show up
oh i would lose it yeah and then i was
listening to that i was calling him
so much no no answer nothing i was
i was like this guy is a piece of work
he really tricked me on that first date
[Laughter]
yeah then i found out he well it's still
not okay that he fell asleep but he
apologized profusely
it's hilarious yeah i wish i could have
seen the look on his face when he woke
up
oh my god realize oh [ __ ] right yeah
yeah how did you
happen from i'm on my way to let me take
a nap because he lies
he's still oh he says i'm on my way
you're not even out of your house yet
yeah but he does that and
it that actually did bother me for a
while in our relationship
because i'd see him do it to other
people and be like i'm on my way and
we're
like not even close to leaving yet and
i'm like why do you say that like why do
you even tell them that
to me it's a broken promise because it's
like
if i'm gonna be late i just would rather
say oh hey i'm gonna run i'm gonna be 15
minutes late yeah
or whatever but i don't like the
disconnect and communication and he's
changed that
since then but in his eyes he just
didn't want to disappoint them
so he was like oh like i want them to
know like i care about them and i'm i'm
like i'm putting an effort like i i
remember this thing that i'm supposed to
be at like i'm there
but um yeah in my eyes it was like no
that's dishonest
yep yeah yeah it that way too exactly
that same way
but yeah cause like when when casey and
i first started dating too he actually
did that too
but it wasn't for something so innocent
like
oh he was actually uh
he was hanging out with other people
like
really definitely i think it's my
birthday too actually what
super death death is he not death kill
him to death
was it my birthday yeah no on my
birthday he was supposed to come at a
certain time and he didn't show up to
like wait like three hours later or
something
i was like damn and i was gonna break up
with him too because i was early on in
our relationship
how do these guys get away with it i'm
gonna call him right now
no just tell him it's okay no he won't
even know why he's not even a while he's
a good boy now
she's waiting to be a [ __ ] let her be a
[ __ ] i've been so good give me
some other guy fine he made amends he
doesn't deserve it no i dated a guy like
that um
that he this was not just one time thing
but this was my learning experience
because
then i was able to see it in the next
guy that was repeating those same
patterns but
um he would say oh i can't hang out i'm
going to bed
and then i would get drunken voicemails
at three in the morning
with like people in the background and
like saying he misses me and stuff
i'm like why why would you sell yourself
out for an idiot
yeah what a [ __ ] multiple times and and
he would do this thing where he would be
like oh let's hang out i get all ready
and then he goes oh i'm actually too
tired and he goes to
he's going to bed and then you get a
voicemail that's like him hanging out
with people
that's so drives me [ __ ] crazy you
made me waste my makeup
you didn't even take me out you broke a
promise
and then you're hanging out with other
people so many red flags
i think another one of mine is like um
when they talk about
their past relationships and they're
like yeah you know like my ex-girlfriend
like she also has like some trust issues
with me she always thought i was doing
something when i didn't
and i'm just like this can go both ways
because either one she could have trust
issues or two what did you do
to give her these trust issues so that's
that's a hard one for me to
determine yeah are you a type of person
that plants seeds to right
manipulate or are you just trying to be
openly exactly
yeah i totally get that because the guy
that cheated on me
was like did that where he was like i
would never
cheat on anybody one time my girlfriend
thought that i was
the like that kind of [ __ ] and then he
did the same [ __ ] thing
right so it's like but i but i feel
but i've been on the other side too i
remember when i was younger this guy's
like you're a very hard person to trust
to date i'm like why he goes you know
just what you do for a living and like
you got multiple guys messaging you all
the time so
throughout that relationship he didn't
trust me at all
you know and i was just like i'm one of
two places
playing games or sleeping you know so
it's really hard for me to kind of
like it's it's not like a red red flag
it's more like it's kind of pinkish yeah
yeah because it's like salmon yeah it's
just lifestyles don't match up for you
yeah so it's like a is it your ex that
was a problem or was it you
yeah trust is huge man yeah definitely
anything that could even go with like
friendships
too though because like when people will
start saying like
oh yeah i had uh like a previous
friendship like in elementary school or
whatever
where it's like yeah i wasn't able to
that person wasn't able to trust me or
they would blame me on dating their
boyfriend or some other crazy [ __ ] where
i'm like
wait what how did i even get to that
point because i've had
situations where people end up telling
me like yeah i didn't understand how
my friendship bless you thank you how
like my friendship
with this previous person ended up
falling out because they were blaming me
for
going behind their back and doing other
things but i'm like where did they even
get the idea from then
where is even like where where's the
seat of thought here like i don't
understand
right but which one's the crazy there's
so many
so many different things that could be
red flags but i think it all comes down
to
um communication and uh don't be a dick
um don't be abusive be nice to waiters
don't lie yeah don't lie cheat your
steal
yeah cause the truth always comes out no
matter what like no matter
[ __ ] what the truth always comes out
and then just make sure with your
partner that you guys
are in alignment you know and that your
expectations are set
and don't talk to nikki when she's
eating don't [ __ ] talk to me
at all so there's a lot of red flags out
there
there's a lot of red flags out there but
i uh we hope that the few that we gave
you
helps you out and maybe while listening
to this you something
pops up in your head like oh my god i've
dealt with this before and now you know
and now you know
ooh accidentally did that or i do that
yeah true yeah
pick up on the patterns yep because i
mean we're all at fault some of us like
we've done some of these before
yeah you know it's just that you learn
from it like you're self-aware you're
like oh [ __ ] that hurts people and then
you learn from it and you don't do it
again
exactly uh thanks for watching guys make
sure you guys give us a thumbs up
or five stars on everything in the hell
everything everything
um if you guys want to follow us on
instagram look at the description box
below all of our stuff's there
leave a comment actually yeah leave a
comment and
tell me what your red flags are yeah
yeah there's so many more and i came
into i walked into this video like when
i was driving here i was like oh
i'm gonna say this and this and this and
then i literally sit down and i'm like
blind it's been a while we're rusty okay
give us a break jess isn't here either
right hopefully she'll be back soon
we love you jess and we love all of you
who does
thanks for watching y'all we'll see you
guys next week we love you bye